le métier du showbiz c'est un métier de
mecs en réalité et home les nanas c'est
très compliqué parce qu'une femme n'a
pas le droit de vieillir après 40 ans
elle est éjecté moi je le vois partout
quoi donc moi je m'accroche parce que je
trouve ça totalement injuste et que et
que les femmes ont leur place mais alors
elle continue quand même jane birkin
chante c'est vrai mais oui mais oui
d'accord mais si vous regardez les liens
on les passe pas les hommes passent
julienc et à la radio les femmes sont
exclues
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on ne passe
pas alors bah si c'est parce que on est
des dinosaures dans les dinosaures vous
emmerde et il aimerait bien passer en
radio
alors c'est dur ce qu'elle dit valérie
benaïm ont été les est-ce que c'est
comme ça alors il fut un temps où
c'était comme ça parce qu'en fait les
filles étaient juste des potiches il
fallait qu'elle soit jolie jeune à côté
de l'animateur principal qu'elle sourit
bêtement match crispant ce décès une
animatrice au plus de 40 ans la télé
apparemment vie d'avant ben moi bien 51
ans jean et karine le marchand qui à 50
ans je trouve qu'il ya une nouvelle
génération c'est la génération qui m'a
accompagné qu'avec avec carole rousseau
avec laurence ferrari
cette génération là on est cette
génération là à avant nous non ça
n'existait pas parce qu'avant nous
effectivement 30 ans c'était la dernière
barrière
merci au revoir rideaux ou alors il
fallait deux journalistes politiques et
là on avait droit de vieillir à
l'antenne mais les animatrices elle ne
pouvait pas vieillir aujourd'hui ça
bouge un petit peu ma génération
olivier olivier quéro quatre producteurs
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce nom je
trouve que est en effet celle à un petit
peu raison quand on a du talent 40 ans
on a toujours du talent à 60 ans et
c'est quand même y en a marre on en a
pas attendre a peint pas c'est sûr mais
c'est vrai que c'est difficile pour une
chanteuse donc on lui met une petite
étiquette toi tu est périmée la surface
et non c'est dur il ya beaucoup
d'artistes qui préparent des albums ou
fait la tournée des stars 80 dont vous
êtes avec des artistes voilà il ya ya ya
ya ya julie piétri et c'est vrai qu'on
les lise entendait beaucoup moins on les
voyait beaucoup moins liée au el hafed
contre pascal un fort caractère
voilà au dehors la chanson mais c'est
vrai qu'au niveau chanson voilà on l'est
on les entendait plus et 6 voilà c'est
sûr que ce sont des artistes qui était
un petit peu mise de côté qu'on a réussi
avec ses tournées que comme âge tendre
qui a pu faire nicole ou ou star 80 rfm
party 80 toutes ses tournées qui ont
existé
on a pu les remettre sur le devant de la
scène d'ailleurs sir in situ me permet
je voudrais juste dire un petit truc en
2006 qu avant d'inventer cette tournée
on a fait une émission de télé qui
s'appelle symphonique chaud et qui était
produit par franck saurat et ce jour là
il y avait un directeur de télévision de
radio de pardon de télévision qui me dit
olivier thual imbéciles parce que tout
est artiste nommé sur une scène de zenit
je suis sûr que ça marche c'est nikola
bisetto nicolas pernikoff j'aurais lui
rendre hommage
rr est brillant combat s'est encore
passé à deux doigts du mad
il a donné n'oubliez pas les paroles à
nagui mais la donne est détournée des
années 80 brahim a tonné touche pas et
se retrouve avec une paire de lunettes
et n'est bon qu'à 130 il ya un coup
d'oeil qui était partagé par amel bent
il ya quelques jours
la jurée du télé crochet on est faut
sauver annick mardi la québécoise de 48
ans dénonçant par la même occasion un
métier ingrat envers les femmes plus à
regarder la musique enfin le métier de
chanteuse
c'est un métier très ingrat pour les
femmes
très ingrat pour les femmes on va dire
qu'à 20 ans tout d'un coup quand ça
marche tu es fraîche tm et puis avec les
années ben ça fait pas comme le vent
quoi on m'en donnait 10
on va prendre la nouvelle qu'à 20 ans et
on sent que les hommes d'urs plus
facilement dans le temps que les femmes
ont leur accepte pas la vieillesse où on
leur accorde pas cette chance alors
franchement moi je vais continuer avec
vous à nyc parce que pour moi vous êtes
un message d'espoir et ça veut dire qu'à
tous les âges
c'est encore possible
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que chez les hommes parce qu'il
ya un truc chez france télévisions
maintenant on m'a dit j'ai reçu un ami à
giuly il ya quelques jours et il m'a dit
quand on est un homme blanc de plus de
50 ans et voilà qu'on peut faire de la
télé on est cuit sur france télévisions
est interminable et ses déclarations de
delphine ernotte
l'adapah tradition donc ça c'est vrai
vous l'avez vous l'avez pourquoi vous
avez essayé de trouver du travail
ailleurs
non non non non non mais j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de monde à une époque alors
d'être fidèle de chez vous êtes fidèles
voilà mais il se trouve que non je crois
que quand on a de bons titres surtout on
passe en radio parce que le ce qu'elle
reprochait se calme on ne passe pas son
de ses nouvelles chansons par exemple
regarder des barbares à des france gall
d'annie cordy des dalida ça passe juste
devant vitaly d'assurer sa passe en
radio
bah oui alors exactement 20 mai bernard
et langue de bois excuse-moi été
extrêmement longue de gauche y est je
suis pas d'accord non plus avec la
mairie alors oui bien sûr ya des
contre-exemples oui bien sûr de manière
marginale ya toi il ya karine le
marchand
mais globalement non l'achat le tir de
loisir de 40 ans sa pub sapin et on nous
fait comprendre ça sent le sapin au
sommet il se faire sur les deux tout
quoi ça sent la fin
mais oui parce que michel ou le sapin le
sapin le tremplin tout court après
est-ce qu'on fait soi on va la regarder
on va la traque et on va les pieds on va
lui dire oh la la la qu'est-ce qu'elle a
pris elle a pris cher l état paie et si
elle se fait refaire la gueule à la
taverne sur l'exemple même temps je
surveille davantage adore souvient elle
avait mis des photos sur instagram
rappelez vous les os et les restaurer
les patrons de chaînes d'accord avec
géraldine parce que je pense que tu
parles d'une ancienne génération en
génération de retard moi je suis
absolument certaine que ma génération
celle de douala des quinquas
d'aujourd'hui c'est nous qui allons
justement vieillir à la télévision c'est
le signe des contrats
je suis persuadé que nous on va on va
être la génération qui allons réussir ce
pari là mais ni sur quelle chaîne
si vous voulez pas des deux aucun cas
les politiques ont fait au moins 49
florent pagny marc lavoine qui sont pas
toutes réservées sk la place ils
pourraient pas mettre nicoletta et
sheila oui oui mais voilà maintenant ce
qui met amel bent et génie parce que
c'est plus frais je suis d'accord alors
nicoletta que souvent c'est moi je pense
qu'il faut agir en artiste quand on a le
privilège de faire le métier que je fais
c'est à dire ça veut dire qu'à 40 ans
quand on sent qu'on est un peu
sous-estimé moins aimé des gens de ce
métier c'est normal on nous a beaucoup
donné donc on peut passer aux choses
passent aux jeunes gens ça tout à fait
normal il faut se jeter un défi sur le
plan personnel
moi quand j'ai eu des petites d'histoire
au moral comme ça dans bêtement je me
suis dit j'adore la musique américaine
j'adore gospel et je sais que passe par
radio d'ailleurs je vais travailler avec
une chorale j'ai demandé une américaine
c'est le connaissait une école de gospel
à paris juste ce qu'il fallait et j'ai
travaillé au bout d'un moment j'ai
travaillé huit heures par jour avant
avec lesquels on travaille au musée le
beaucoup de travail ma culture
il fallait vraiment que je travaille
très fort vous êtes vous agir autre
chose j'ai mis 6 mai sur les routes des
églises des cathédrales écart abyssal et
que c'est une musique chrétienne ça
m'intéressait d'aider cette musique
merveilleuse qu'est la grand mère de
toutes les musiques mixtes c'est-à-dire
africaine ou américaines chance est la
grand-mère pour moi de la soul music et
durera sort d'alain provision de gospel
selon la proviseure aussi dans low cost
et et j'adore ça et je me suis jeté ce
défi et ça a marché
j'ai reçu un trophée de lapin d'affairé
sont françaises du gospel m'adore ils
m'embrassent dans la rue ils me disent
merci
c'est mes frères et ma pelle sisters
voilà moi je suis très fier
avec la femme savoir avec l'artiste il
faut rester un artiste peintre bien
pourquoi on a choisi ce métier il faut
compter sur le choix du public
madame on parle on parle de l'aln et
nicoletta l'adulte du showbiz et c'est
vrai que dans le showbiz je suis pas
d'accord avec toi j'ai pris je pense que
franchement en profondeur rien n'a
changé pour une femme bien sûr et que tu
peux être productrice qui est karim
d'ailleurs elle a compris qu'il fallait
qu'elles sont productrices pour durer
malheureuse mais sont le sabre à peine
cent des femmes non par l'état
je suis une artiste indépendante voilà
nous produisons nous disent qu'avec mon
compagnon gilles allant partenaires
comprennent pas le poste de télé vallori
de jouer quand je me plains pas parce
que le show biais chaque fois que je
fais quelque chose il magret il m'aide
il ne s'est pas évadé a baissé dans le
showbiz bah c'est vrai mais à l'antenne
j'ai merdé
madame moi je trouve avec tout le talent
que vous avez je n'ai pas normal que
vous soyez obligé de bifurquer de
changer pour continuer à être usée
muller sud ou le soudan mais ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que sheila pour
moi son coup de gueule il est salutaire
metioui c'est du sexisme aujourd'hui
quand on est quand on est une femme qui
a plus de 49 et bien on est écarté de la
télévision
oui mais là on parle pas de saint
nicolas des radios télévisions et moi
d'être là c'est le public qui vous
choisit mais en radio en télévision ce
sont les directeurs des programmes et
nous allons là où tant reçu que moi dans
les médias télévisuels
oui mon radio quand on sort quelques
autres au mur oui mais oui mais on ne
nous boude pas en deux mots les villes
efforts souvent nicole tu constates bien
que quand on fait des émules télévision
on nous on nous demande des fois d'avoir
des textes ou des playbacks de certains
chanteurs parce que on va refaire
chanter la chanson par une jeune tu
comprends ça à chérac c'est un peu mieux
jbg l'original monsieur voulait les
faire chanter par une jeune oui mais tu
comprends notre côté déjà d'anciens
combattants du ca dans les chaînes sur
mes amis tous les jours j'ai des
émissions tous les jours on me demande
des paroles les extrêmes alors on passe
un extrait du clip de l'original mais
l'original elle est chez elle à la temps
elle se voit elle voit sa chanson en
direct à la télé c'est pas normal qu'ils
ont gentiment la vie évidemment on n'a
pas du tout dérangé
au contraire le succès de cette émission
m'a fait beaucoup de bien sur le plan
promotionnel oui mais il est minime
je suis pas sur le même combat de toute
façon non mais n'est pas ma filiales il
ya beaucoup d'avenir une île de plus 40
ans comme vous qui font des choses
formidables et c'est très bien qu'ils
connaissent des succès ce qui était
libre mais ne me retourne nicoletta là
pour elle elle s'en sort très bien géré
mais l'homme sur ton parce qu'il est
déplorable c'est que les médias ne met
pas en avant ces artistes aujourd'hui
tous les artistes qui sont mis en avant
dans les radios musicales les uns
conditions étaient dures je suis d
énormes est arrêté alors que la lnd gare
à la raison celle là on n'écoute plus
des nouveaux titres délaissés car il ya
trop de gens qui t'aiment
elles sont présentes et maintenant je
suis en radio et justement vous êtes
sûre même radio et bien justement c'est
la radio musicale la plus féminine de
france donc je veux parler en
connaissance de cause mylène farmer 59
en asie 5 ans cette liane foly lara
fabian sa diffusion de nouveaux titres
on passe ne sait pas bien sûr que si
vous rigolez qu'en asie elle sort un
nouvel album nous intel vient alors
vrai mais c'est naturel radio isabelle
vous évoquez jules radio je reviens au
ksar es 2 0
le problème avec sheila je pense que
c'est un problème de génération c'est
une queen mais si elle ressort un type
qui s'appelle tous y est gay c'est trop
désuet il faut juste se mettre un petit
peu à la dragée être un petit peu plus
de temps dans son jeu m radio 100 est un
poème de seniors à chanter lui et moi
pourquoi ce qui fait ma radio je pense
rarement des nouveaux titres sur un bras
d'eau aujourd'hui aujourd'hui en télé je
vous le promets nicolas la raison mais
là peuvent le nicolas peut le constater
dans de dire qu on nous demande souvent
un artiste pour son succès de l'époque
m'a bien sûr jamais pour son nouveau
titre
tu crois toujours un enfer on me dira
oui jusqu'à 500 bateaux gens qui
chantent aux champs elysées et me
laissant là bas c'est vous qui nous sort
me revient jamais bien je l'avais vu il
est fort mal mais elle sort de nos
pratiques mais cannes mylène farmer se
montre pas qu elle mylène farmer qui
avait milité tout du sisal valérie elle
vit dans un monde totalement idéal non
c'est vrai il ya une sous représentation
et valérie on va dire ça je peux vous
dire quelque chose
ouais on va dire la vérité sur votre
histoire aleri quand un moment et on
peut pas dire qu'il y en ait beaucoup
s'étaient pas lié à mon âge c'était lié
à un échec d'une émission précise
vous n'avez jamais de chez moi qui m'en
aller maintenant mais il faut être
honnête vous ne faut dire aux gens
il ya un moment quand vous faites une
émission qui ne fonctionne pas les
lâcher
oui mais la chaîne en question se dit
c'est pas le concept en règle générale
c'est l'animatrice qui en pâtit et moi
je trouve que c'est normal parce que
quand c'est la gloire mais c'est
l'animatrice qui en a tout le tout le
tout la gloriole donc quand c'est un
échec c'est bien que ce soit elle aussi
que je règne sur elle et en l'occurrence
mais là j'ai fait les frais des pots
cassés et on m'a dit merci au revoir
disharmonie avec beaucoup d'animatrice
et aujourd'hui n'existe plus bien sûr on
roule et alexandra bankers qui n'a
souffert elles sont tous les tina
kieffer exactement jury de le faire a
fait le choix de partir après c'est
clair
bonsoir ironique à loubry les coeurs
c'est toutes ces braqueurs ce magnifique
séverine ferrer à bitam et léry sur tf1
quand tu étais enceinte
le discours de téva autre chose oui mais
quand même abbas était en moi j'en ai
vraiment on travaille ensemble sur
célébrité c'est vrai que ben a été
magnifique elle était enceinte je sais
que les actions de tf1 ça les dérangeait
pas ce qui d'abord effet appris que
directeur des programmes de l'époque qui
se reconnaîtra est qui et qui m'avait
dit partie moment où tu es enceinte
comme ça va commencer à se voir
tu peux tu peux rester à la maison les
montants à verser huit enceintes c'est
pas une maladie
donc je vais être la première animatrice
qui va présenter une émission est
enceinte que je prenne 10 20 30 ans 40
kg peu importe je suis une femme
enceinte et d'ailleurs j'ai bien j'ai
bien fait parce que j'ai reçu une tonne
de courrier les gens ont adoré voir
enfin quelqu'un qui fait les femmes en
tout cas les ce qu'on appelle la fameuse
ménagère qui monte qui m'ont envoyé des
petits mots me disant ah bah enfin une
femme ont relaté les enceintes
il ya plein de téléspectateurs qui me
disent et toi cyril takoucht ans